hello everyone
and
welcome
to the
talk
by dr leslie gross weston
she is a postdoctoral associate with the
council on african studies and
teaching fellow at the center for race
indigeneity and transnational migration
at yale
um she will be talking today about
outsourcing otherness
with race and belonging in the morocco
eu
border
so the way the
seminar is going to be organized so
first
leslie is going to
um
sort of introduce the topics and discuss
her give her presentation
and then she will take
questions
after her presentation
if you could please you can send the
questions on a chat or just raise your
hand and then we'll
make sure that placement replies to you
make sure you introduce yourself and say
who you are she just sent a chat as well
if you want to have a few words
okay so i think
leslie if you want to start
all right um can everyone hear me thumbs
up
okay wonderful
all right um well thank you very much
tedessa for this invitation to speak to
you all today and to be here with the
program for refugees forced displacement
and transnational uh i'm sorry and
humanitarian response
and tarana too who's doing a lot of the
back of the house work right now
you know facilitating your she'll help
facilitate your questions and let people
into the room
um in general i just am grateful to be
here at the macmillan center um that
houses this program as well as the
councils on african studies and middle
east studies which has been just a
wonderful place to think about migration
and border enforcement
and um thank you to those of you who are
here today uh i just want to welcome you
and encourage you to use the chat to
introduce yourselves to say what brought
you here
um to
you know pose questions or ask questions
of each other as well as me
and um after i talk for a little bit
we'll we'll have some time hopefully for
not just question and answer but for
kind of a more um
collective discussion because i think a
lot of people are bringing all kinds of
professional and personal experience
into this
um
so this is one day after we in the
united states commemorate indigenous
peoples day and i want to locate myself
here on the traditional land stewarded
by the quinnipiac people
who were subjected to violent mobilities
of colonial settlement and forced
displacement that continue to shape the
geography of the u.s settler state so
i'm really mindful of when i talk about
mobility and violence in other contexts
that i am
very much interpolated both in that
context and in my home country and my
home um
geography as well
so uh
like that as i said i'm hoping to talk
to you for about 30 to 35 minutes um
and you know and then we'll have time
for discussion
so today i am drawing on my research on
the your african border in morocco to
make the case that race and racism and
especially in the context that i
investigate blackness and anti-blackness
are central to determinations about
whose mobility is subject to control and
how that works
so before i go any further though i want
to unpack a few terms so when i talk
about the your african border i'm
speaking of the network of governments
law enforcement agencies humanitarian
organizations defense contractors
smuggling rings and other entities that
are implicated in the control
of people's migratory movements between
africa and europe
and this network has grown out of the eu
and individual member states shift in
the mid to late 1990s toward outsourcing
immigration control to neighboring
countries whose participation is
enlisted through various diplomatic and
financial incentives
and just a little side note nora el
cadim is a person who problematizes
maybe the incentivization of the
externalized borders so if you want to
know more about that i encourage you to
look up her work
most scholars call this sort of
outsourced border the externalized
border or border externalization and
you'll hear me refer to it in this talk
in that way
so in the externalized border walls and
fences certainly play a role and
definitely draw much of the media
attention
but the border signifies something much
more expansive it's a political and
economic complex whose reason for being
depends upon the criminalization of
certain groups of people's cross-border
movements
further borders aren't just inert
barriers be they physical institutional
algorithmic legal or social but active
processes of inscribing inclusions and
exclusions throughout social space
so in this way borders are productive
they aren't just about restricting or
inhibiting but they're generating
relations subjects and spaces
um so when i talk about race i'm not
referring to unchanging identities or
categories whose meaning is fixed across
time and space but instead i understand
race is a category of difference
produced through ongoing processes of
racialization with local and
trans-regional as well as historical and
contemporary valence
so what this means is that being black
in morocco for example is not the same
even though it resonates with being
black in the united states and as we'll
see in a bit neither is being white in
morocco the same as being white in the
u.s or in mauritania or in south africa
or in countries in europe
when i argue that race and especially
blackness is central to mobility control
in the euro african borderlands it means
it isn't just that the border targets
black people but that it produces people
as black
collapsing their multiple identities
into a single figure of the black or
african migrant and further it assigns
meanings about blackness that legitimize
the violence against people conceived as
fundamentally out of place not just in
morocco or europe but within the realm
of the human
um and by the way slides and pictures so
you don't have to look at me the whole
time are coming but i just want to get
this introduction first
so to unpack this i'm going to tell you
a story about a conversation i had in
the midst of field work in 2017 and 2018
among west and central african migrants
who found themselves stranded in morocco
this story points to the ways that your
african border is not just reorganizing
transnational economic relationships or
challenging notions of sovereignty and
territory which are concerns that border
scholars have taken up
but is reworking the social and
significant ways across morocco and i
would argue by extension throughout the
year african borderlands
my approach builds on decades of
feminist critique of scale and
ethnographic research in order to
understand how the bodily and the global
mutually constitute places and people
thus thinking about the border
ethnographically requires attention to
the daily embodied experiences of people
who encounter reproduce and transgress
it and in my work i argue that migrants
are implicated in all of those actions
so through a relational lens i trace
connections rather than distinctions
that characterize the borders operations
and migrants experiences in specific
places within what reuben anderson calls
the extended field site the your african
border
all right so i'm going to share my
screen with you now
all right
um
so i conducted most of my field work at
bezen mcness which are two central
moroccan cities that have been host to
growing numbers of west and central
african populations this is in part due
to the moroccan state's shift a few
years previous to this research from a
practice of apprehending migrants in the
northern part of morocco which i refer
to as the frontier region or the
frontier zone near fences that separate
morocco from two spanish enclaves malia
and siege
that you can see on the map
formerly the state had rounded up folks
attempting to breach the fences or cross
the mediterranean on boats or sometimes
just rounded people up who were
phenotypically black in the northern
cities and dropped them off in the
desert at the algerian border
this practice has been widely denounced
by human rights associations in morocco
and in europe and was replaced as part
of a humanitarian reform of morocco's
border policy
so what replaced it instead were these
internal deportations in which any net
black non-citizen in the words of one
report in the frontier zone were still
rounded up but rather than dropping them
in the desert they were drop they were
bus south to cities in the country's
interior
this practice of pushing people back
from the northern border zone to more
remote southern locations mirrors the
eu's region-wide strategy of pushing
migrants from its southern and eastern
borders into countries like morocco
libya and turkey
these are countries that have fewer
resources and infrastructures to
accommodate them
and uh
um i think part of this border
externalization and the pushing back
that is happening or creating a buffer
zone is something that just keeps
getting replicated replicated on a
smaller and smaller scale
so
once in fez or meknes migrants were
often dropped off near the train station
or bus station and encampments were
established uh in empty lots adjacent to
them and this is true not just in fez or
mcness but in many cities across the
country
many people newly arrived from the north
stayed in these encampments or moved to
overcrowded rooms in working class
neighborhoods where they survived by
begging on the street or
engaged in informal work
one effect of this policy was that the
it heightened the visibility of west and
central african migrants on moroccan
city streets reinforcing the link
between blackness and unauthorized or
undesired migration
this heightened visibility and
conflation of blackness with illegality
impacted different communities within
morocco in several ways
so first it concealed the fact that many
of the people migrating to europe from
morocco without papers were in fact
moroccan nationals
second it reframed how people perceived
the presence of many sub-saharan
students with legal papers
so these sub-saharan students have long
been present in morocco and actually are
brought to morocco through a program
that the state sponsors
and finally it's impacted black
moroccans whose belonging has always
been racialized but is now being
animated by anti-black migration
politics and that's kind of what i'm
going to focus on today
so in fez i worked closely with a
research partner freddy or as he likes
to say he had a driver
several times a week i would meet him at
the mcdonald's in downtown fez where we
would have a quick breakfast and then
spend the next six or so hours visiting
migrant communities in an in the outdoor
encampment adjacent to the train station
or in a working class neighborhood
freddy wears lots of hats himself a
former migrant from cameroon who took
the land journey from morocco when he
was a teenager he's now a social worker
with a church-based ngo and with a
moroccan-based ngo focused on hiv
prevention
he's also the leader of the cameroonian
community by virtue of his seniority in
the country and his important positions
with ngos
in his social worker role he responds to
urgent health and social services needs
of all black people as he says in fez
people from cameroon nigeria guinea mali
ivory coast and so on
his phone never stops ringing rounding
up blankets for newly arrived people
dropped off at the camp by moroccan
border police calling supervisors to ask
for the release of funds so he can pay
for prescriptions for
migrants who are experiencing
hypertension or
to purchase insulin for diabetes
he accompanies he's accompanied pregnant
women to their prenatal visits to
provide translation
identifies bodies at the morgue and
arranges for a burial in a popper's
grave helps someone arrange their
self-deportation
and will file applications for one year
regularization program uh for moms and
for mothers and children
and as cameroonian community leader he
mediates disputes between individuals
visits people in prison and while i was
there arranged for a sex worker who was
not getting along with her madame to be
transferred to a madam in another city
so that she could be safe
often when i dropped him off in the
neighborhood in the early evening he had
hours more calls and visits to make
so after six or seven months as
freddie's chauffeur i took a short
vacation to the toffeeload located in
the southeast of the country near
morocco's fabled sand dunes the
toffeeload oasis system runs along the
aziz river between the provincial
capital of roshiria to the north and air
food the gateway to the sahara as
tourist operators like to say to the
south the toffeeload has fascinated
generations of anthropologists also for
its diverse entangled cultural religious
racial and ethnic makeup arabs jews
black black or arab berbers descendants
of slaves so-called white berbers
descendants of the prophet the shortfall
or of holy people and so on
um and we can talk more about that in
the q a or i can point you to some
excellent resources including hussein
illahian's work
so though i didn't travel to the tofilt
to study the border i encountered it
anyway the internal deportations that it
contributed to more west and central
african migrants living in and stranded
in pheasant mechness were now being
diverted to more remote and economically
marginal towns further south or further
in the moroccan interior including both
rashidia and air food each a short
distance away from where this picture is
taken
indeed in fez i met many people who had
been pushed back from the northern
border to rashidia to bini malal or to
tisneet before making their way back to
fez or heading back to the northern
frontier to try to cross the border
again
so on my visit to the tuffylo i was
chatting with fatima zahra an amazing or
berber activist about my research among
migrants experiencing these internal
deportations and how i thought the
practice seemed to be reinforcing or
intensifying anti-black discrimination
against both migrants and black
moroccans
she responded with the local version of
the argument i've heard many times since
moving to morocco in two thousand one in
the tophill to there have been african
immigrants for centuries as a result of
the trans-saharan slave trade but
despite their unfree status they
suffered no discrimination in moroccan
society
pointing to a sepia toned picture of a
traditionally guarded man on the wall
she said
my grandfather owned two slaves and he
treated them very well
the problem in her view arose from
changes in land tenure that it allowed
le noire
by which she was referring to both the
descendants of enslaved west africans
and indigenous black or arab berbers
access to property formerly controlled
by les blanc
which would be non-black
berbers in addition because descendants
of enslaved and black indigenous people
were now considered members of tribal
groups they were able to sit on local
councils and influence decisions about
developing or selling off communal land
she traced a square on the table with
her fingers and added now that african
migrants are arriving in the region the
amazing are being invaded on all sides
so there are many things that we can
unpack about this vignette that speak to
the specific character of racial
politics in morocco including questions
of indigeneity race descent
property regimes kinship and affiliation
but what really struck me about these
very local struggles with decades and in
some cases centuries of
built on centuries-old categories of
social difference
and corresponding power and resource
inequalities was that they were being
interpolated into this very recent
transnational your african border
so what i'm going to spend the rest of
our time on today is showing how the
border is producing the social
especially in regards to race in places
far from the walls and fences and how
the politics of belonging in morocco is
increasingly being articulated in the
register of race
and i want to touch briefly on how
outsourcing or externalizing
border enforcement from europe to its
neighbors can enable the concealment of
european culpability but it also can
offer a way to trace the borders logics
and operations across vast spaces
next i'll discuss morocco's racial
history and contemporary context in
which the border intervenes and then
finally while blackness is consolidated
as a signifier of otherness i propose
that it is facilitated or deepened
mobilizations against white supremacy
throughout the your african borderlands
okay uh teresa i'm assuming you will
intervene if there's something going
wrong so i'm just going to keep going
because all i see is the same is the
powerpoint
so my co this i just found this map and
i think it's wonderful because it
gives you a sense of this externalized
border so it according to this map the
blue dotted line which goes through the
mediterranean um is sort of
where the european border is imagined
i'm not exactly sure why why it runs
through turkey in this case but
maybe we can talk about that um but then
you have the neighbors you have north
africa who um north african countries
who participate in containing and
preventing migrants from other their own
their own people and then also from
other places from reaching or crossing
that border
and then um
i think what this map also shows is that
the externalized border is moving
further and further south through
various other kinds of research
partnerships so that the whole journey
from say for example cameroon to
libya or to morocco
is heavily bordered and is overlaid with
various agreements between states and
contractors and and other people
so my colleague lorena gazzotti and i
recently authored a piece that subjects
analytical concepts common to border and
migration studies to postcolonial
critique
we argue that uncritical use of
externalization runs the risk of
reproducing colonial narratives of
europe as the agent of history
following i know corbin syria we argue
that externalization's presentism the
idea that it's unique or and also that
migration is is is new or is a crisis
is a historical european powers have
been subverting african autonomy for
centuries as martin lindberg peterson
has argued and imposing various mobility
regimes that facilitate or
suppress the movement of precarious
people
nevertheless externalization also
enables us to move beyond uncritical
analyses of border enforcement that
center individual states so it allows us
to trace relations of power and circuits
of capital that structure the
transnational heterogeneous your african
border
when used critically and historically
externalization can help us discern the
connections that obtain across scales
and among different actors
by bringing such connections to the fore
we can track transmission national
circulations of race and racist
ideologies that are central to the
animation of local specific racial
formations and histories in places like
morocco
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
these histories before turning to how
they articulate with border
externalization in morocco
today wonder if i can move this i don't
know if you guys if that's in the way oh
i'll just leave it
for a long time there's been silence
around the subject of race in morocco
both in public conversations but also an
academic scholarship where it's often
folded into discussions of ethnicity
despite this silence race and
racialization permeate moroccan and
maghrib societies
shuki al-hamel points to the
pre-colonial and islamic roots of the
black white binary suggesting that
perhaps the islamic mediterranean
influenced or shaped the racial
hierarchies and
that became entrenched in the americas
the trans-saharan slave trade
reverberates in moroccan social
relations as evidenced
by the use of the word elabed slave to
refer to a dark-skinned moroccan and the
persistent idea that phenotypically
black berbers are not actually
indigenous
the colonial project in morocco and
across africa has linked whiteness to
superiority and modernity and blackness
to tradition prehistory and
underdevelopment
today the accretion of anti-blackness is
discernible in myriad ways that include
racial profiling by security agents the
casual use of racist language by
ordinary moroccans and the frequent
appearance of blackface and racial
stereotypes and entertainment and media
and you can see an example here this is
a really famous example that came out
recently because miriam hussein here
is expressing her solidarity with u.s
protests the black lives matter protests
in the united states in the wake of the
murder of george floyd and the way that
she decided to do this was to um to wear
blackface
so as anthropologist laura menon has
argued racial formations and racisms are
local partic particular and contextual
this is a common position among both
historians and anthropologists working
on questions of difference in the
maghrib and the african continent as a
whole
what's important about this perspective
is that it safeguards against imposing
analyses or theories derived from other
contexts to the moroccan one
but going back to the point made at the
beginning about scale context is never
only local and indeed the local is
always bound up in relations that extend
well beyond the particular location
i think fatima zachara's story gets at
both this relationality and its
contingency morocco is not a blank slate
when it comes to race relations or
racial politics but neither is it closed
off from the past or present global
racial ideologies
and geopolitics
tracing the border as it connects as
well as separates africa and europe
makes it possible to see how race
circulates is transnationally
constituted and bound up in systems of
power that cut across local and
international reworking intensifying
unsettling and refusing meanings in
various places
so again europe's outsourced border
enforcement program and the ensemble
that now comprises the your african
border is impacting not only notions of
blackness but reinforcing hegemonic
conceptions of whiteness across moroccan
social space blackness which has long
been a signifier of inferiority in
morocco has become consolidated with
illegality with riskiness and without of
placeness
sticking to use sarah ahmed's term to
other people who are not explicitly the
targets of border violence
so this is the case with timothy hux
timothy hux was a u.s english teacher
who while living in rabat was rounded up
by police and internally deported to the
south of the country he had stepped out
of his house to run a quick errand and
left his passport at home
police did not believe that he is a
black man was a u.s citizen and thought
he was an undocumented migrant
lorena gozzotti has written about how in
morocco black people are routinely
policed and deported regardless of their
legal status while at the same time
white europeans who overstay their visas
can expect few consequences
none of them violent or immediate
while hux eventually returned to robot
and then to the united states and i
think his citizenship had something to
do with his ability to to move
um
al alan tussan another teacher and legal
resident originally from the democratic
republic of congo was similarly rounded
up and died after being thrown from a
moving bus during an internal
deportation
[Applause]
so oh sorry so the conflation of
blackness with out of placeness attaches
to black moroccans as well
during field work black moroccans
recounted examples of how other
moroccans would mutter racial epithets
under their breath like at the hanus or
market assuming that the person didn't
understand moroccan arabic and in a
poignant example that a friend told me
about
he was watching in 2017 he was watching
a sports program and a moroccan tv
journalist was on the streets in
casablanca interviewing people about an
upcoming soccer match
when the journalists encountered a black
moroccan he switched to french assuming
the man was was a foreigner the man
replied in moroccan arabic they went
back and forth like this uh with the
interviewer not believing the man was
moroccan until he finally said in
exasperation aisha malik long lived the
king
in contrast whiteness has gained more
salience as a way to assert one's
authorization in space at the national
scale but also at other scales so like
fatima many moroccans that i spoke to
would probably refer to their identity
uh as white in ref i'm sorry as their
identity is muslim arab or berber
perhaps jewish or more commonly just
moroccan
but referred to themselves as white in
reference to black or african migrants
so drawing a distinction between
so-called african migrants and
themselves helped them to fix a boundary
that aligns the maghrib with europe at
the expense of producing africa using
the language of european apartheid as
beyond the pale
the global pandemic has exposed how harm
is directed to racialized gendered and
othered people in society structured in
dominance the murder of george floyd and
brianna taylor in my country has
provoked worldwide protests and
solidarity with black us citizens but
it's also prompted testimonies from
black arabs and other black middle
eastern and north african people about
the pervasive discrimination that exists
both in the diaspora
and in their home countries
significantly many of them are naming
the marginalization and violence they
experience as anti-blackness and
expressing solidarity with black
migrants and other african diasporas so
these are two social media campaigns
that i want to just talk about for a few
minutes there are many of them that have
proliferated in recent years
um or in recent months i should say
uh so
kajuanusnus and black moroccans are uh
are providing platforms for black
identifying moroccans and members of the
moroccan diaspora
black moroccans as far as i can tell is
also affiliated with activists and
artists who were involved in the 2014
campaign
which is uh my name is not ezzy uh
as he connoting a very pejorative word
for a black person
so both of these instagram accounts like
other accounts that focus on the gulf or
iran or the arab world as a whole are
comprised of a mix of historical and
contemporary images of blackness in
morocco as well as testimonies
of black and afro-identified people
speaking to their experiences with
anti-blackness in their home countries
and this is one example i i think that
this is the organizer of a half-half but
i haven't gotten in touch yet to confirm
that um
so many of these testimonies explicitly
point out that racism is not just
something that happens in the united
states or in europe but it's something
that's also woven into the moroccan into
moroccan society
and these instagram accounts provide a
platform where moroccan nationals and
europeans of moroccan descent reject the
pressures to orient toward whiteness
instead embracing blackness and
africanity along with moroccanists
europe european europeanness indigeneity
or arabness
they write and speak about identity and
sociality in ways that destabilize not
only the manichaeanisms of black white
binaries but also monolithic ideas about
racial identity and belonging
their commentaries invoke the local and
moroccan specificity of blackness and
anti-blackness and how these are
entangled in transnational and
trans-temporal notions of value and
humanity
i i think these are really exciting
i could go on i'll uh i'll i'm gonna
wrap up really soon but i could talk
about these for a long time
so tracing um the afterlives of slavery
and european colonialism they connect
the condition of the haratin in morocco
and mauritania to that of liber in
france they interrogate the role of
anti-blackness in islamic history and
jurisprudence they protest foreign
capitalist and militaristic
interventions and so on their
epistemology epistemological vision is
relational and social
simultaneously grounded in place in
specificity and mindful of the larger
cross currents that we all get drawn
into
black moroccans with its roots in
immigrant solidarity and anti-racist
activism and the more recent
half-half emerge from i would argue
amelia shaped by the your african
borders production of blackness as
otherness
the transnational project of bordering
blackness has also enabled west and
central african
migrants black moroccans moroccans in
the diaspora experiencing anti-islamic
or anti-black discrimination to assemble
a transnational african diaspora that
refuses blackness as negation and
instead understands blackness as
conditioning the possibility for new
internationalist and decolonial futures
i think that's the last example yeah
okay so um
i think that essa is going to help me do
this but if you have questions you can
um put them in the chat or i don't know
what do you think ted said they can
unmute themselves yeah they can
interpret themselves there was already
one question on the chat from vaslim um
about the
map that you show so i think if you want
to
if you want to
show
us the question yourself sure okay yeah
um so thanks for the question tess lim
so you said are the yellow bits um
countries that are partnering with north
africa
to protect the red border
um i think a lot of that so
i guess i'll go back to it but i think
that um most of this because a lot of
the funding is still uh driven by the
european union these are partnerships
that comprise sort of multiple layers of
of partners that include often europeans
north african states and um
people in the estates in the sahel in
western africa for example so i don't
think it's tiered in the sense that
uh morocco and tunisia and algeria and
libya cooperate with europe and then
you know mali and mauritania and nigeria
cooperate with morocco and algeria but
instead it's you know it's these
multiple layers of programs that
contribute to that across the board
and i see a question from lydia
um
that asks if there are any moroccan
researchers working on on these topics
blackness externalized borders etc and
moroccan universities
so um i think the answer to that is yes
uh there are
particularly working on the topic of the
externalized border there are quite a
few
both
doing research
i mean
affiliated with institutions in europe
and north america but also working
within morocco when i first came to do
research in 2017
i met with three researchers from
meknes who were doing phenomenal work on
the border
and on migrant experiences there um
and i'm
kishkish is the last name i'm blanking
temporarily on their names but i can
pass them along
in addition my colleague and i lorena
and i um just co-edited a volume for the
journal of north african studies that
came out online this summer
that features a few people for a few
researchers from the region and actually
one migrant um
uh who who's speaking about the
externalized border and their experience
in morocco so um yeah so that's some of
that in terms of blackness i do think
that there are some people and then from
the north african diaspora who are
starting to ask these questions
university of pennsylvania the middle
east studies department there has had
some really interesting work um
i'm really bad with names afifa
withdiffy i believe is
i think from tunisia and is doing that
is thinking about these questions from
um
from a historical point
perspective
and yes of course saeed murad points out
as well saeed said sadiki has been
talking about this for a long time
and then of course um in terms of
blackness shooky alhamel literally wrote
the book on blackness in morocco and
that book has recently been translated
into arabic
okay um zenib asked uh what did i mean
by release relational epistemologies and
and this is when i was talking about the
instagramers
um i think
i think the emphasis that i'm trying to
make here is that these phenomena are
neither local completely local nor
completely um
like
deterritorialized or global only but
they are constantly in relation to each
other and that also the way that these
um these protests are seeing them
themselves is not compared in a
comparative sense where they're trying
to
uh
show that antibiotics in morocco for
example is commensurate with maybe
anti-arab or anti-islamic racism in
france but trying to constitute or
organized
[Music]
organized solidarities that recognize
that a lot of this has to do with white
supremacy it has to do with capitalist
development and even development in the
world it has to do with you know long
histories of colonial intervention as
well
any other questions or con i i'm also
really happy to hear from comments from
folks too
i imagine you have opinions
okay so iman um
said i was wondering if you could talk a
little more about how the presence of
sub-saharan africans in morocco
conceals the fact that many of the
people migrating to europe from morocco
are actually moroccan nationals and how
that affects the morocco eu relationship
thanks for that question that's these
are really great questions all of them
um
yeah so
i think
this is something that i talk about in
some of my other work but the way that i
think about it is that in morocco's
participate participation in the
externalized border is often framed
as containing or preventing the mobility
of people from sub-saharan africa
and you know as many of us know moroccan
nationals constitute the largest
um
non
largest
non-national population in europe many
of whom of course arrive by legal means
but not all
um but it's reworking when i first moved
to morocco in 2001 there was a lot of
discussion and you see this in the in in
literature as well a lot of discussion
about moroccan migrants or moroccan
immigrants who are trying to get to
europe
and um i feel like that discourse has
shifted despite the fact that really the
numbers of people moving from morocco to
europe from
west or central africa are still quite
small
so i think it it reframes uh
for morocco it reframes the problem of
migration if migration is at all a
problem as something that is that is
from outside that is from west or
central africa rather than something
that is um
that is related to moroccan nationals
themselves if that makes sense
um
and of course you know the eu is also
addressing
the issue of moroccan national migration
um but one of the things that they do in
exchange for morocco's cooperation is
offer more short-term visas for
date agricultural laborers and people
like that as well as student visas and
facilitate some of the ways for people
to go work
in europe or join family in europe
more easily but some of that is at least
in theory contingent upon morocco's
cooperation
in keeping and central africans out or
keeping them from crossing the border
does that make sense amen
yes thank you so much
um this is tesleem i i wanted to ask you
if you see parallels in
this
situation here uh relative to the
the u.s um
south american like we had this
caravan
i'm just gonna use the words of the
media used so um the caravan and coming
through and then
the u.s
trying to partner with mexico to
to make that border further i mean
that's it kind of reminded me of this
whole situation here when you describe
the the moroccan situation i'm wondering
like what are the powers and differences
yeah that's a great question i think
there's a lot i think there are a lot of
parallels and now i'm going to just
make things up but i feel like the eu
sort of pioneered this in the in us
jumped on board but i i could be wrong
about that but i do know from from
people doing research in mexico
that there's increasing numbers of
central american
migrants who are stuck in mexico and the
us is pushing them back right instead of
um they're trying to intercept them
before they cross or right as they cross
the border so that they don't have to
deport them they can push them back into
mexico and then it becomes mexico's
problem and the conditions for central
americans has gotten much worse and my
understanding from
you know uh
from
folks to either doing research in mexico
or actually just from from mexicans that
are that are living there is that um
discrimination and and uh sort of
anti-indigenous race
racism has against central americans has
become a huge
um has
has become significant in the way that
the the uh central american migration is
characterized now in mexico
and i think the us i don't know i know
that the us funds some of that just the
way that the eu funds it but don't you
know donald trump apparently doesn't
know that so
because that also that um
like i think like the frontier zone it's
it's starting to feel like that too on
that
border on the mexican
side of the border of
that space where
yeah people who are stuck were
setting up completely now that asylum
claims are either not being processed or
processed so slowly um that there's just
in a mat like more and more people are
amassing on that border
um and then of course you know the
united states has a hundred mile buffer
zone around all of its borders
um so
that's it's that's another thing and it
can act with a certain level of impunity
that doesn't apply in other places in
the in the tear in american territory
so yeah
hi um
thank you so much leslie for your talk
um i was curious if you can speak to the
sort of humanitarian laws governing um
this deportations um because i am
curious i
i'm thinking so much about you know
african migrants who are going into
italy and you have you know these
italian boats that are supposed to save
them and then you have these asylum laws
and you have of course the humanitarian
laws that they can't you know um
this
i don't know i think i can't i
encountered this concept of reform mere
in thinking about the south american
border where you can't you know legally
send people back or in danger so is
there any sort of
i mean this partnership between the eu
um is i guess quite concerning when
thinking about the laws that also the eu
um and the un uphold in terms of
humanitarianism yeah that's a great
question um
well i'll just say the first thing that
comes to my mind is i get so mad when
people are rescued in the mediterranean
by being sent back to libya right or or
i get i get morocco i have like a google
alert that says morocco and migrants and
they'll say like um moroccan you know
coast guard rescued
a certain amount of migrants in the
mediterranean
um when really it's like intercepting
and pushing them back or bringing them
back to moroccan territory so that like
discourses humanitarian discourses get
really enmeshed and that isn't to say
that there isn't a lot there isn't
rescue also happening in the
mediterranean but those discourses get
really enmeshed with security and with
securitization and so it's a really
complicated situation
um in 2014 morocco
for which they should be lauded reformed
their migration policy
and
some of the things that they did was to
offer two periods of exceptional
regularization where people could
actually get residency permits
for a year or more a year and it could
be renewed
um
in addition
they at least on paper at least
aspirationally uh would provide uh
healthcare and education for kids and
for other people
um
i'm trying to think what else left the
top of my head but those are like pretty
significant particularly if you think
you know if you compare them to uh the
context of the united states right now
it is something to be lauded but
what it did is kind of put people it you
know it kept people from traveling where
they wanted to travel and in some cases
it just
uh
put them on hold because they were still
not able to get jobs um you know they
were still experiencing police violence
they were still at the risk of being
rounded up at any moment and being
mistaken for someone that didn't have
residency papers um also there were
limits in terms of who got regularized
and who didn't and how long you had to
have been there and whether you were
there at the right time
so um
i think actually probably a little bit
more than in the united states mexico
context humanitarian language and sort
of liberal discourses about human rights
get deployed a lot um but not
necessarily um
they're not they're not inscribed into
law uh in the same way and um
you know just to do a little bit more
press
or the shameless promotion the journal
of north african studies
um special issue that just came out on
this uh has some articles that
specifically address that and one of
them is by katsavina natter and she
talks about how
um
you know how the sort of liberal
discourse and humanitarianism
on the moroccan state enables it to be
authoritarian in other ways so uh you
know we have the hedok
conflict or
repression i guess you would say and
we're seeing a lot more media
experiencing oppression in morocco
um women have been subjected to court
cases related to their sexuality
and things like that so there is a way
too in which this like humanitarian
language conceals other kinds of
behavior
so that's those are some of the things
that i'm thinking of off the top of my
head does that answer your question
faith yes thank you so much
okay great
um jennifer you said
yes when you talk about resistance to
the fact
or regarding uh
jennifer can you tell me what you said i
missed the first part can you clarify
sorry i had ridiculous improve type
that's um i do that i was just
it's um how you talked about
resistance against black indigeneity um
and just this discourse around blackness
of not belonging to place and so i'm
curious if there's also like settler
claims to indigeneity going on here um
with anyone else who's not necessarily
from morocco who
um
necessarily identifies black and so gets
that access
right
so there's a lot going on that i
understand
some um but i am really not
the person so i'm gonna gesture to some
things but i would not be the person to
unpack this in detail
but first indigeneity is kind of a weird
concept i think it translates
kind of i use that but it translates
strangely partly because of the french
there's a little bit of a foes on me
happening there um in morocco
um but this denial of black indigeneity
or maybe black
amaziah identity has to do with this
conflation with blackness and slavery
that shooky alhamdulillah talks about so
the idea is if you're black you're
always from somewhere else
um and you know very common the most
common
term that i heard when i lived in
morocco that people would address black
people by was sahrawi like person from
the south i mean from the sahara
and so this idea that you're from
another geography from another place
would deny you know your right to
presence but there's also this dynamic
in morocco where morocco itself is a
settler state right because it's
occupying
western sahara and there's all kinds of
really interesting racial dynamics in
western sahara as well
so yeah so there's a lot going on there
that i think would be fascinating for
someone to unpack but uh
it's not it's not the main focus for me
right now um the the region the toffee
lot where this came out for me is such a
such an interesting and diverse and very
region with a lot of history and culture
um that i haven't fully apprehended or
investigated and so i think you know
someone who would do a really nuanced
study of some of these questions would
do well to
kind of dive into that literature and
think about it from that aspect
thank you
yeah no problem
uh
lydia have i studied the specificities
of blackness and robot the capital
um i haven't i haven't no um
so the bulk this is actually in some
ways this paper is the follow-up to my
research because the bulk of my research
is really focused on how
um the your african border produces
migrants as black in order to legitimize
violence against them and sort of to
consign them to this other place right
to this
um
you know zone of non-being if you want
to put it that way or the un-geographic
is how catherine mckittrick talks about
it
so i and then i also think about it in
terms of political economy
but the
um
the way that the border was impacting
moroccan society more broadly and i
could see this a little bit as kind of
an outsider that was traveling and
living there frequently
i moved there the first time in 2001
just a few weeks before september 11th
in the united states
um and then you know return periodically
for one or two year periods um you know
through 2017. so i was able to see how
this was sort of
uh this uh blackness
illegality migration is crisis all of
this discourse was becoming more and
more prominent in morocco over the two
decades or so that i've been
you know living or moving around there
um
so definitely you know you hear i've
heard things similar about robot but i
haven't done a particular study of robot
okay zenib
says i've read about how moroccan
authorities have a habit of quelling the
formation of anti-racist civil society
for a variety of possible reasons have i
been pressured in any way or approached
by the authorities while conducting my
research
um no that's you know so so my one of my
external advisors is michael collier
who's been doing research um on
migration in morocco in the region since
like 1997
and you know he's really careful to
emphasize that one of the reasons we're
able to talk about morocco as a violent
border state or
you know racism in morocco or things
like that is in part because they allow
researchers to come and ask some of
these questions so you know you can't do
this research in algeria as easily as at
least as an american as a us citizen
um
uh
so
so in that sense no i haven't been
limited in another sense
you do have to get a research permit and
so i was encouraged by my host
organization to be really careful about
how i framed these questions and to
speak in generalities and in fact my
partner was doing um historical research
on the reef which is sort of a much more
um you know it was right in the midst of
the hirak reef uh kind of movement there
and he wasn't given a research permit
and in fact his um
you know was was told not to do research
so
you know so i think it varies by topic
but morocco has been
um
fairly accommodating to people who are
doing research on migration despite you
know
most of that research being pretty
strong in critique
if we have a couple of minutes um if
there's not other questions i'm
interested to know a little bit more
about this uh political economy that you
mentioned and i think that was a big
part of your
research and and
how it feeds into this whole situation
right yeah so you know in some ways i'm
still i'm still
puzzling that out a little bit but
um
there's an anthropologist reuben
anderson there have been some other
people as well but he really wrote about
um
uh
the border like this transnational
border between europe and africa as an
industry
that that exists um to cert kind of
circulate capital based on the
illegality or the production of
illegality of migrants and other other
scholars have done that too so the idea
is again that you know that the border
can only exist as long as you're
criminalizing people who are moving and
beyond that that it feeds um it feeds
itself by um
uh
you know uh through the accumulation of
capital so i'll give an example to be
less abstract um so basically when the
when europe infuses money into
you know grant's big defense contractors
and in the 1990s you have to remember
this is like after the fall of the
berlin wall and the cold war was sort of
officially over and so suddenly you had
all these defense contractors who um
didn't have markets anymore to sell
their you know to sell their wares or
their weapons and their technologies so
they repackage them for civilian use
and have um advertised them as being
able to track migrants and and to
protect
migrants is one of the ways one of the
languages that they use so that so um
that sort of has kept the defense
industry for a while that kept them
going for a while and it's become you
know the expenditures have become higher
and higher and i would point to the
transnational
institute and mark ackerman who who is
someone who's done research on that
and then of course as borders get
stronger and it gets harder to get
across and you have smugglers right who
are also
um suddenly you know not making a little
bit of money just helping someone like
directing them through the desert
somewhere but suddenly you know having
to buy gear and night vision and you
know all of these things and also can
charge a lot more money to migrants and
refugees who want to cross because it's
gotten a lot more dangerous and they
need their specialized expertise so
um you know there's a certain group um
in the south of algeria who i think
during the refugee crisis of like of you
know
2015 said they made something like a
billion dollars i mean i don't know if
it's true or not but um there's
tremendous money in that and so what i
do is try to link that to race and think
about it through racial capitalist lens
where it's not just the production of
illegality criminalizing people but it's
also the production of race that making
people who are black and are on the move
um
uh you know targets of the border
both defense contractors states
but also humanitarian agencies and also
smugglers all of these people are like
trying to get a piece of the pie
um
it becomes it's driven by sort of a
racial logic so that's that's where i
connect those two things together
i'm still thinking through how that
works and what the utility of a racial
capitalist
idea is but i think it also political
economy we often think of as centered
around labor and i don't think this is
centered just around labor it's not just
about bringing
people from africa to europe in
precarious condition and being too able
to exploit their labor but it's actually
just exploiting their movements and
their bodies and making money off of
that so that's what that's what i'm
focused on
does that make sense
go ahead hey leslie um
first civil um i'm i'm so sorry because
i i missed the bulk of your talk and i
think
last five minutes because uh
um i had actually prior meeting but i i
find this really fascinating just from
the q a and the questions are being
asked but i i just wanted like probably
my question
more on the
your research and i find that and you
just mentioned this um my understanding
is that lately there has been like sort
of strict rules actually in between your
permission
um as far as like sort of migration
because and you actually mentioned this
just earlier the fact that
you know it's so sort of paradoxical
that the state would give you permission
and you have to go through all these
little polls
however a lot of research that being
produced you sort of skate into the
state or serve sort of like skating
critique of the state
um and i i'd like just to hear a little
bit from you as far as like the uh
generalization that you've mentioned
that like sort of you know to get like
sort of research permit you have to
somewhat tweak
um you like your questions which
which which can be problematic sometimes
because there's always this sort of like
oh you yeah and i know this very well
like even like you know people that
wanted to do
um research in western sahara and they
would not even be allowed to actually
even come close to their or even have
any sort of interlocutors which is
really really hard anybody that that
would even envision doing research there
would not be even and i know someone
that tried to
serve like try to work on divorce and
tweak things to be able to get even to
that territory uh serve long-winded but
could you
you know could you say a bit about it
because it's really sometimes so hard
because also when you're doing research
and you want to get elixir for your
search permit there are all these
committees and things you go through
that you have to sort of like say here
is what i'm really doing and at times
you might also have to
um i think about egypt just to give you
an example you talk about algeria where
at times like people even having
uh you know wanted to play for the
fulbright and actually get the fulbright
they were rejected because there are
certain questions that the way they
formulated the questions
um
sort of was not welcomed by the
committee or by the states i just want
to hear a little bit about especially
that you've spent a lot of time in
morocco back and forth with your partner
and doing a lot of work there and like
are where are there any where i probably
had a very you know very like clear road
you didn't have a lot of obstacles also
probably because of your affiliation
uh but i want to hear more um this sort
of tension between
you know yes you can get your permit
however it's a very repressive system
that's really careful about what people
write about it
and still they are skating critique i
hope i'm making sense
yeah totally totally i think
um i'll answer that question and i'm
also i'll zoom out a little bit to sort
of ethics in general
um and also just you know my position um
not only am i a white american um but i
had a research affiliation with a very
prominent uh
university in morocco ella hawaiian
university and i have a long history
with them
so i you know i was i'm let i was
leveraging a lot of my privilege that um
other researchers might not have access
um you know if you're south african
you're not they're not gonna let you
like come to the country
probably much less uh you know must
let's do research and you know there's
lots of other examples so
um you know so i think that was part of
it and actually i mentioned talking to
the three mcnessie
researchers and um when i was first
starting and i was like well how you
know how do you go about getting access
and you know
going into the camps and stuff like that
and they said oh you're a white american
no problem you just walk right in you
know and so there are ways in which
um that position
for better or worse and probably for
worse um
you know enabled me to do that in terms
of generalities i'll be really honest
i'm an over discloser if you haven't
noticed that already in this talk
and i um i wrote out very detailed
research proposal for the ministry um of
foreign affairs in the ministry of
interior and then somebody else
that was in the sponsoring institution
edited it for me
and you know probably had a better eye
for the sort of political nature project
and how i should do it but i mean i
think there's an ethics too to what you
disclose and what you don't disclose and
how you
um yeah and also like what you go in
expecting to see and i think my
situation was a little different because
i'd been in morocco for so long and it
already encountered um you know the
experience of being with migrants who
were you know who were experiencing
violence and
over policing and things like that so i
kind of knew what i was probably going
to find but i think we also have to
think about that and be really careful
for going in expecting to find
you know racism or expecting to overlay
our particular um
you know epistemological orientation
onto a new context you know that can be
problematic as well so
yeah so i so i think it is something and
i think it was helpful for me that i was
you know affiliated with a moroccan
institution not just for the
you know for the
kind of greasing the wheels but also
because it kept me a little bit more
accountable to scholars who were doing
similar work who were from the country
or who were long-term residents of the
country and so i didn't feel like i was
quite so much of you know a lone cowboy
doing a lot of this work and had some
accountability
not just to my research um interlocutors
uh west and central african migrants but
also to other folks
in the you know in the region who were
experts on this and were you know
asking me questions and talking through
these issues with me as well
thank you so much leslie i mean and the
reason really why i ask you that because
i know someone who recently actually
wanted to do similar work um and it was
actually rejected but i but you're right
the whole politic of access and
affiliation i mean it absolutely makes
total sense thank you yeah no problem
and i do i will say i think morocco is
getting a little stricter on research
permits so that is true
there is a yeah there is a question from
liz christmer and
so if you can reply to these two
questions i think this will be the last
two ones
okay so liz i
um don't know if i can talk about the
externalization externalization of the
border in morocco and how it plays out
through technology and data collection
in part because um a lot of the
uh from the state perspective the
ministry of interior is the one who
keeps the most accurate and i'm sure
exhaustive data on this and they're not
telling anyone
so um you know so that's sort of a black
box i know that in terms of unhcr
uh you know migrants are fingerprinted
now and that has to do with um where
people can make asylum claims and this
push to get people to you know seek
asylum in morocco and other third
countries rather than in europe
itself
so those are the two things i really
know about data in morocco that hasn't
been something because my research was
so ethnographic among migrants it wasn't
something that
that i encountered that much except you
know sort of death by paperwork and
especially the regularization um process
you had to submit a ton of papers you
had to get a police report you know if
you could find your birth certificate
and all of those things and from my
perspective that was a really effective
way to get more information and better
sense of who migrants were where they
were from how many there were
and just keep track of people so i do
see the regularization program
as also being a way to keep that data
but again it went to the ministry of
interior so and i don't know who they're
sharing it with
and then amen
have there been moments in your field
work where you were emotionally affected
by what you've seen and heard yes
um
yes there definitely were um
but i i would say one thing is that the
people that i was with were so
we're just living their lives right
western central african migrants were
have had really hard times um
things were often really bad but they
were also oh my gosh sorry a bird just
hit the window
um uh things were really bad but they
were also
not victims right
in sort of this unidimensional sense and
so being with them
um
and that sense of community that that
that was in those communities always
lighten the load i mean that's the best
way that i can say it
um and not just i think for me but also
for them i think where i felt heavier
was when i came back and was going back
through my field notes and writing it up
and i found writing i actually
one i found writing it up really hard
but second i decided not to include very
many examples at all from my field work
so a lot of my book manuscript is
drawing on just a few anecdotes and
unpacking them because one because i
don't want to expose people in that
particular way
um especially when it's at their hearts
sometimes at their hardest or their
their lowest spot
and also because i just i think there's
been enough there's been plenty of
documentation about how hard it is to be
a west or central african migrant on the
move
and um
you don't need more specificity from me
on that so that's kind of how i dealt
with that i should also just add that
you know
um
really the reason that i came to this
project it wasn't my original intention
but having lived in morocco i just met
migrants and i was a member of the
protestant church in morocco which
became you know
really started diverting a lot of its
attention to helping migrants many of
whom were filling the congregations
across the country and so
for me um it was really just about kind
of looking around at where i'd been and
and what was happening there in a
country that i actually i love i love it
my first child was born in morocco and
it's a place that's really special to me
um but i wanted to think more about um
how
what these changes are that i'd
witnessed over two decades were really
about and and also to locate a lot of
that culpability or responsibility in
europe and more broadly in white
supremacy and the legacies of
colonialism
and racial capitalism so that's kind of
that's what brought me to this project